[Music]
the Westminster accounts investigation
watching a new debate about money in
politics here's something you genuinely
haven't been able to do before I think
transparency is really important for the
healthy functioning of democracy
revealing the scale of outside earnings
over
17 million pounds
showing you which MPS bring in the most
this is the leaderboard the more
transparency the better
asking who funds our democracy we're
trying to get in touch with people from
npm connect there doesn't seem to be
anybody here I want to have that debate
again I want to clean up British
politics
a project designed to show the public
how money moves through politics a new
tool that anyone can use to see who
gives and who gets asking the questions
about the transparency we were always
told we had now raised on the biggest
stage in Westminster let's reflect upon
numbers and in particular the numbers
that were shown away on by Sam Coates of
sky does a prime minister not find it
utterly perverse that senior members of
the conservative party are Feathering
their nest in this way ultimately
Westminster need to reform the smp's New
Westminster leader says the revelations
in our investigation demands change
everything needs to be on the table we
have a situation where senior MPS are
working in millions former Prime
Ministers but what's more worrying is
the fact that we appear to have in peace
or receiving money significant sums of
money from organizations who nobody
really knows what they do or why they're
giving MPS that money in the first
instance that's a huge concern to me
it'll be a huge concern to the public
what surprised you the most about the
Westminster accounts and the work that
we've done what what has shocked you the
fact of the you as a reporter can attend
at a place where you're anticipating
seeing a high-tech company I think it
was and there was nobody there that's
that's utterly bizarre this is our
democracy MPS are there to make laws
which govern our lives and we don't know
where the money is coming from or who's
behind that money that's a serious
threat to democracy yesterday it was the
head of an Ethics Watchdog that issued a
call for change around the transparency
rules for MPS today it was the turn of
the leader of the third biggest party
Stephen Flynn of the SNP who said we
needed root and Branch reform now make
no mistake lots of MPS are worried about
the transparency exercise that Sky News
and tortoise media have done once said
it was just a Witch Hunt against MPS but
quietly more and more people around here
are coming out and telling me that there
is a case for changing the rules
this debate just beginning but the
Westminster accounts project and the new
level of transparency it brings are here
to stay Sam Coates Sky News
and if you scan the QR code on your
screen right now it'll take you to our
Search tool where you can find out how
much money your MP receives in addition
to their MP's salary while it's all in
the Westminster accounts a project by
Sky News and tortoise media just scan
that QR code on your skate screen and it
will take you straight there